I like to read things to be up on what
people are trying to say like I love
getting the feedback from everyone Kim
Kardashian explains why she likes
Keeping Up With The public's opinion
about her famous fam people don't see
the context behind it yeah some celebs
avoid reading headlines about their
lives but during the latest episode of
who's the Kardashians Kim says she's all
in and not afraid to address the critics
there was an article about season two of
our show that said that Chloe didn't
give enough with her Tristan situation
with my surrogacy I was so vulnerable
we've filmed everything from deliveries
to marriages divorces you know the show
comes out so many different stories have
been made up of course during season two
Khloe opened up about welcoming a second
child with her ex Tristan Thompson
shortly after learning he cheated and
had a baby with someone else I was
definitely very angry and I think
feeling
Bamboozled Chloe and Tristan split after
his latest infidelity and welcomed their
son Tatum in July I have no guilt
because I show so much about my life and
I am okay you always have as for Kim she
addresses the haters who accuse the show
of not featuring her ex-husband and the
father of her four children Kanye West
it's not that I'm unwilling it's that
the my ex didn't want to be on a reality
show I will definitely talk about my
co-parenting struggles but from my point
of view and talk about Kanye is just
what she did during the season 3
premiere he has made up the most insane
narrative and I have to sit here
and not say anything ever
because I know one day my kids will
appreciate that of course the Kardashian
Jenner fam has been sharing their lives
ever since their first reality show
Keeping Up with the Kardashians debuted
in 2007. welcome to my family
I'm Kim Kardashian it's a ton of work
and it's a lot of it's a commitment and
every single one of my family members
said I'm in and Kim she says she has no
plans of throwing in the towel I just
love doing this show because I think
that I look at it as an opportunity to
like help other people with what they're
going through I think for every sister
we have different boundary levels we
need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that cameras were
rolling for tons of personal moments
from Chloe's 30-day jail sentence for a
DUI in 2007. I totally know I should not
have been driving so irresponsible to
Kim and Kris Humphrey's proposal wedding
and split 72 days later
Chloe's 2009 wedding to Lamar Odom was
documented they got engaged after just
30 days of knowing each other from this
day forward you are husband and wife
but with the good comes the sad the
series filmed their divorce which was
finalized in 2016 after he recovered
from an overdose in 2015. he's doing
better every day for sure which is a
blessing but it's going to be a long
road and of course Kim and Kanye's
relationship played out for the cameras
from the early days of dating to his
baseball stadium proposal to their
Italian wedding and the birth of their
kids
four is the perfect magic number for me
I just think like our show is like what
made us like I'll always want to give up
my all I'll always wanna
film and and be a part of it